encuentra el área de un cuadrado cuyo
lado mide 6 x 5
que dibujamos por aquí nuestro cuadrado
ahí está nuestro cuadrado y cada lado
del cuadrado como es un cuadrado todos
sus lados mide lo mismo entonces cada
lado del cuadrado mide 6 x menos 5 y ok
entonces este lado mide 6 x menos 5
y por lo tanto este otro lado también
mide 6 x menos 5 y así es que si
queremos calcular el área área de este
cuadrado lo que tenemos que hacer es
multiplicar base por altura o sea
multiplica
x 5 x 6 x menos 5 g y aquí tenemos
varias opciones una es seguir lo que nos
dice pau
está
y nuestra querida amiga pau y la otra es
utilizar la propiedad distributiva
si te gusta mucho memorizar cosas y
hacer las cuentas de una forma mecánica
entonces puedes usar lo que dice pau o
puedes simplemente utilizar la propiedad
distributiva que ella a mí me gusta más
utilizar la propiedad distributiva
entonces vamos a multiplicar todo este
paréntesis por cada uno de los elementos
que se están sumando en este paréntesis
ok entonces nos queda igual a 6 x 6 x
por todo nuestro paréntesis x 6 x menos
5 y menos 58 menos 58 por todo nuestro
paréntesis o sea x 6 x
58 y ahora volvemos a aplicar la
propiedad distributiva vamos a
multiplicar este por este soy que nos
queda 6 x x 6 x que es 6 x 6 36 36 x x x
x cuadrada más este 6 x x menos 5 y
entonces lo que nos queda es 6 x menos 5
eso es menos 30 y aquí tenemos x y ya
por x por jay y por aquí tenemos que
multiplicar menos 5 y todo esto de aquí
no se nos olvide multiplicar el menos
por 6 x y entonces nos queda menos 5 por
6 esto es menos 30 y después x por james
menos 30 por x por jay y finalmente
menos sin coche por menos 5 y ahora aquí
tenemos menos por menos o sea que nos va
a quedar un +5 por 525 y georgia
de cuadrada gay ya casi terminamos aquí
el único detalle que nos falta es que
aquí tenemos x por qué y por aquí
también tenemos x porque entonces
podemos sumar estos dos términos y nos
queda un solo término menos 30 x menos
30 x y eso es igual a menos 60 x x ya y
nos falta poner por aquí más 25 de
cuadrada y 36 x cuadrada ok estas dos
cosas son iguales y listo ahora sí ya
encontramos el área ahora si necesitas
hacer esto rapidísimo pues puedes
reconocer que esto de aquí es
simplemente un binomio al cuadrado
esto de aquí lo puedes escribir como
6 x menos 5 y he elevado al cuadrado
porque estos dos son iguales porque este
es un cuadrado y para binomios al
cuadrado tenemos una fórmula directa si
tenemos por aquí a más de al cuadrado
nosotros sabemos que eso es exactamente
igual a más p por a más
y si hacemos todo este desarrollo que
hicimos por aquí pero con ive en lugar
de 6x y menos 5 o cualquier otro valor
que queramos sustituir por a y por d
entonces lo que hacemos es aplicar la
propiedad distributiva dos veces y esto
es igual
tomamos esta a y lo multiplicamos por
todo este paréntesis entonces nos queda
a por a más
y a eso le tenemos que sumar esta vez
por todo este paréntesis a más b y ahora
volvemos a aplicar la propiedad
distributiva en estos dos paréntesis y
nos quedan apurada es una cuadrada más a
por b aporte más b por qué en realidad b
por a es lo mismo que apruebe por ve más
b por b que es b cuadrada que hay
entonces tenemos estos dos términos que
se pueden sumar y nos queda que aprobé
más a por b simplemente dos por a porte
y aquí simplemente bajamos estos
términos
a cuadrado ok esta es una forma de
encontrar esta fórmula del binomio al
cuadrado otra forma un poquito más
directa podría haber sido decir que
tenemos que multiplicar cada uno de los
términos de aquí por cada uno de los
términos de aquí entonces toca a por a
que es nuestra a cuadrada más a por b
que es una de las aves más ve por a que
es lo mismo que aprobé entonces ya
tenemos dos de esas a por veces más b
por b que es de cuadrada ok pero bueno
el chiste es que si ya sabemos que si
tenemos un binomio y lo elevamos al
cuadrado nos queda esta cosa de aquí
entonces podemos simplemente sustituir
6x igual a 5 x igualdad de y entonces lo
que nos queda es que tenemos por aquí
6 x menos 5 elevado al cuadrado y
entonces sabemos que esto es igual a
cuadrada más 2 ave más b cuadrada y el a
cuadrado este es l
entonces 6 x al cuadrado 6 x al cuadrado
más dos veces a por de dos veces a por b
6 x menos 5 cheques nuestra vez más de
cuadrada que es menos 58 al cuadrado
menos 58 al cuadrado
aunque y entonces haciendo estas cuentas
tenemos que 6 x x al cuadrado entonces 6
al cuadrado es 36 x al cuadrado y quizá
al cuadrado más 2 x 6 x menos 5 entonces
en realidad es un -2 por menos 5 es
menos 10 por 6 menos 60 x x gent x gent
y finalmente más menos 5 y al cuadrado
ok menos 5 x menos 5 eso es 25
y al cuadrado entonces ya tenemos que
nos quedó exactamente la misma cosa como
tenía que quedarnos y bueno en este
vídeo vimos muchas formas de desarrollar
binomios al cuadrado el chiste es que si
encontraste este patrón desde el
principio y esta fórmula te parece muy
natural no tienes que hacer todo esto de
usar la propiedad distributiva dos veces
puedes simplemente usar la fórmula y
sustituir los valores de a a bbb claro
que si lo haces de esta forma también
está muy bien y seguro no te equivocas a
menos de que te equivoques en las
cuentas pero espero que no